this country is under a national curfew
here in la vie it's effective as of 10
p.m at night local time you're no longer
allowed on the streets and you're not
supposed to show any light through your
windows
now our small team and large amount of
gear left the city in poland where we've
been staying at about 9 30 this morning
the trip to the madika crossing was
clear sailing and then you hit the line
now as vehicles wait to get to the
border you're passed over and over by
empty buses they're picking up refugees
who are on foot and taking them to
refugee processing centers ukraine is
running 27 right now there's one very
close to the medicare crossing
now leaving poland you go through their
border and then entering ukraine you go
through theirs considering it meant
entering a country that's literally
fighting a war was actually quite easy
then came this moment when we pulled out
of the border facility and saw thousands
of people waiting on foot to get through
there were audible gasps from our team
moving from there the shock came from
the lineup of vehicles we were driving
against car after car bus after bus this
line stretched for about four kilometers
people sat engines off and waited the
crossing into medica poland is the
busiest of any border being used by
ukrainians to go to any neighboring
country in fact according to the numbers
put out by the ukrainian border guard
it's actually twice as busy as the
crossing in second place
from the border and into the town of
levive we passed or were stopped at
about a dozen checkpoints people were
still building them fortifying them now
arriving in la viv it felt quite normal
there was fairly heavy traffic things
seem to be somewhat busy
but then at about 9 00 p.m local time an
air raid siren everyone in our hotel was
told to go to the basement that lasted
about a half hour but it's something
people here are getting used to it's
been happening fairly regularly in this
area despite the fighting not really
happening in this part of western
ukraine the curfew that is in place
stays in place until 6 a.m
mike armstrong global news leve ukraine